hey everyone this is VJ master co-co-co
bouzouki here for chest coms youtube
channel and today i'm going to be doing
a new mini series about the one and only
magnus carlsen today we're going to
start off by showing his recent win over
Hikaru Nakamura the American super GM
and this game took place near the final
rounds of the recently concluded Tata
Steel tournament in why Kansai and this
was a very strong tournament which
Magnus Carlsen won pretty handily he
beat a lot of really strong players and
didn't lose any games and this is one of
his finest wins from that tournament as
he really just more or less outplayed
and destroyed you know the number one
American player Nakamura so the opening
we got was a kalashnikova Sicilian it's
very similar in nature to the special
akov because black gets this backwards
pawn on d6 but generally a pretty solid
position and very playable for black and
here Magnus chose to move g3 which is
not one of the main lines but this is
very indicative of Carlsen because he
often doesn't fight for an opening
advantage but instead just wants to get
a normal playable position and try to
outplay his opponent in the middle game
and even deep deep into the endgame so
Nakamura chose to play h5 here this is
already kind of an improvisation but
this move does make sense to try and
annoy white along the H file here so
Knight c3 threatening 95 so black is
more or less obliged to play a 6 and b5
now black is starting before so white
plays Knight d5 all these moves are of
course more or less standard with the
exception being the h5 move but I don't
think that's such a huge issue yet and
your Nakamura play 97 which I don't know
considering how the game proceeded I
really have to question this move
because black got into some trouble
later on by not being able to develop
their dark squared Bishop Bishop g2 and
now Bishop g4 so now Kimura continues to
play very kind of provocatively he
induces this move f3 and then he goes
back with the bish
to e6 so c3 this is a standard move
White's just trying to play Knight c2
and Knight III or even night before in
some cases black played h4 justifying
his idea and now Knight c2 and this is a
very good move by Magnus Carlsen a lot
of players would make the mistake here
of possibly playing g4 which would be
quite dubious positionally since that
would just lock in their LightSquared
bishop for good and give black possible
control over some of these dark squares
around the Kings side but Magnus simply
ignores this H pawn which is of course
the right decision here the point is is
that black continues with h3 blocking up
the King side is not really so good for
them after Bishop f1 White's going to
put pressure on this b5 pawn by means of
a 4 and blacks position is actually
pretty uncomfortable here wise king will
be perfectly safe Castle kingside
because the position is blocked up and
also trading these rooks along the h5 i
think only helps White's since they're
still going to be able to Castle
queenside and have a very safe position
for their King while blacks King Otto
knows more or less going to be stuck in
the center here and probably suffering
note that in all these lines black can
never play the move g6 because of nine
of six checkmate so you know this is a
reason why I'm kind of skeptical about
developing this Knight to e7 so Magnus
correctly assessed that you know this H
pawn isn't really all that annoying and
simply plays Knight c2 and now he's
going to play Knight e3 neck so nakamora
decided to take this knight on d5 but
you know not allowing Wyatt a chance to
play 93 and solidify this fantastic
outpost now the reason I thought that
this bishop might have been better on d7
was because I think black should really
try and keep the splice scored Bishop
considering how the game continued and
it would have been better maybe to trade
knights on d5 so what I mean is that
back here if black had played Bishop d7
let's say C 3 H for night c2 here Knight
takes d5 and assuming white takes back
with the pawn something like 97 and I
think this would have been more
reasonable then I can come to f5 the
bishop
out and I think blacks position will be
a bit more solid than what happened in
the game which was kind of a mess and
rather unharmonious and was actually
punished very quickly by by the great
Carlsen so after 92 Nakamura decided to
take this night
forcing white to capture with the pawn
and play Knight a5 and now Carlsen
played a very simple but very strong
move f4 so he just got the advantage of
having the two bishops and when you have
the two bishops of course you want to
open up the position so that your
bishops can roam free and have lots of
targets and this f4 move does exactly
that and I think black is already in
some pretty serious difficulties that f5
was played g4 this is another good move
this is just pushing the Black Knight
back into either the e7 or the h6
Squares both of which are bad forcing
black to play this move h3 - played
Bishop b4 and now Queen h4 check King f1
black doesn't actually have anything
despite giving this check the knight has
to go back to somewhere like eise Evan
and then after Queen e2 I think White's
position is much much better he's going
to play a four at some point Bishop e3
rook g1 and and none of blacks pieces
are on good squares well white white is
doing pretty well here
despite his King being on f1 so because
that check doesn't really lead to
anything nakamura decided to play knight
h4 sidelining his second Knight and
Magnus punished this very swiftly and
effectively he's simply castled and now
at some point he's threatening possibly
to take on e5 and open up the F file so
now can we replace ecigs finally trying
to get his Bishop into the game Carlsen
played King h1 a nice profile like to
move getting his King out of any
possible danger Bishop g7 and now f5
Magnus keeps this Bishop locked in and
threatens to try and cause trouble for
black on the King side and although the
game is pretty complicated here it's
actually wasn't that difficult for
Magnus to finish the game off and for a
player of his level when you give them
such a big advantage you know in space
and development and in peace activity
then it's often a case that you're just
not going to survive
so Nakamura took played Knight G - this
is probably the decisive mistake of the
game he should have played Bishop f6
here to stop white from achieving this
break but nevertheless White's position
is still much much better so after
Knight G 2 + f6 the game is more or less
over the point is that Bishop takes f6
we have Queen f3 and we're hitting the
f7 pawns of the bishop can't move and
black is basically busted if rook h4
counter attacking the e4 Bishop we have
Bishop g5 crashing through so Bishop f8
was forced and now Magnus simply brought
all of his pieces into the game and and
destroyed this black King here he played
Queen f3 Queen c7 was played Knight B
for Knight B 796 now this King is going
to be stuck in the center for the rest
of the game and as you can see Magnus
isn't really rushing he's just putting
all of his pieces on very good squares
and when the time is right you know of
course you'll find the combination will
blow - to win the game so Knight c5
Bishop f5 of course we don't want to
give up our powerful LightSquared Bishop
97 Bishop g5 you know why it's just
getting ready to break through here
Bishop e6 is on the agenda at some point
rook g8 was played Queen h5 Nakamura
play Knight b6 you know of course at
this point there's not a whole lot to
suggest here Bishop e6 with deadly
threat of 97 after which y is just going
to crash in on the f7 square now come
over tried his last chance here rook
takes g5 but it was of course too late
to for any kind of salvation here Queen
takes g5 f take c6 and Carlsen had
already seen long before that after F
takes c6 why threatens f7 and block is
completely lost so this game was a
pretty good example of how dominating
Magnus Carlsen can be you know
especially if you give him a good
position from the opening which he
doesn't often get but our plays his
opponents anyways but once he does get a
good position and gets the initiative he
very very rarely lets his opponent off
the hook regardless of who they are
thanks lot for listening and I'll see
you around on chess calm